while citizen-soldiers from all 50
states are answering the call to help
their neighbors get through this crisis
to Pentagon says nearly 19,000 Army
National Guard troops are now deployed
all around the country senior
investigative correspondent Catherine
Herridge is at a Training Center in
Maryland that's of course just outside
the nation's capital Catherine were used
to seeing the National Guard deployed in
a natural disaster a tornado or
hurricane this is kind of a national
50-state disaster but what kind of role
are they're playing well that's right
Tony and good morning Maryland's
governor tells CBS News that he's in
constant contact with ahead of his
state's National Guard they have regular
morning briefings as they work together
to navigate what's next it's sort of
like a terrible hurricane that but
instead of hitting one state that's
hitting all 50 states and it keeps
coming every day and it keeps
intensifying and getting worse like so
many governors across the nation
Maryland's Larry Hogan is watching the
unfolding crisis in New York City and
relying more than ever on his state's
National Guard we actually believe here
in the Maryland DC and Virginia area
where maybe about two weeks behind New
York and we're going to be the next hot
spot we're doing everything we can Major
General Timothy Gowen leads the Maryland
National Guard we've got a lot of
missions our number one mission is to
help with the medical surge and in any
way that we can in Maryland Gowens teams
are fanning out across the state in
Baltimore the guard set up cots for a
field hospital at the convention center
a COBIT 19 testing site at FedEx Field
home of the Washington Redskins and
they're moving pallets of face shields
and surgical gloves to where they are
needed most how is the National Guard
filling the gaps I was one of the very
first to call up the National Guard we
caught we caught up 2200 members of our
National Guard just every kind of place
where we can help our hospitals we can
help provide the services and fill the
gaps they've been doing a tremendous job
and stepping up these are citizens
soldiers who who got called up to go
serve and every time we call on them
they're always they always answer the
call this week the defense secretary
told CBS News the guard may be asked to
do even more I served in a guard for
many years I know what they can do
they're very
capable I'm very proud of what our
Guardsmen are doing but we have a whole
lot more capacity out there in the guard
out to do more maryland's more than 6
million residents are now among the
nearly 90% of Americans ordered to stay
at home are you prepared to enforce the
stay at home order it's a mission that
we're capable of and we're trained for
it we haven't been asked to do it yet
for now the Maryland Guard is preparing
for the expected surgeon fatalities
mid-april and they're also delivering
hope the guard can bring a sense of
community at a time when people feel
very isolated they really do you know so
it could be the opposite you could see a
bunch of folks in fatigues and you know
military vehicles and it could be a
scary thing and say well this but it's
not it's a relief when they come in
people say help is on the way and these
guys are coming in here and they're
gonna help keep us safe
general Gowen said it's a marathon not a
sprint and he has plans in place to swap
out units and people for the long haul
Anthony yeah Catherine thank you